зосередити ваш вашу увагу на наступному
Ми протягом останнього тижня чуємо
питання від представників влади від
деяких експертів А чи варто було в
Верховній Раді голосувати за повернення
додаткової винагороди в розмірі 30 000
для військових
насамперед ми маємо пояснити що Крок по
призначенню додаткової винагороди
зробила влада в прийнявши Постанову
Кабінету Міністрів ще в лютому
2022 року на початку війни очевидно що
не розраховуючи на її довготривалість а
можливо взагалі не розуміючи скільки
буде продовжуватися ця війна і яка
кількість
потрібно буде в Збройних Силах Влада
запропонувала такі додаткові винагоро
винагороди окрім того деякі представники
із офісу президента Вже дали назву цим
виплатам як тридцятка Зеленського і це
щось дуже довго взагалі в таких речах
популізму мало би бути менше Але що
залежало від нас ми дійсно не могли і не
знали чи є кошти для таких додаткових
виплат в бюджеті тому ми не ініціювали
таких винагород а діяли в межах і в
рамках бюджетного кодексу України тому
коли в січні
2023 року
Влада абсолютно не обговорюючи це
питання знову ж свої постановою вносить
зміни у виплату додаткової винагороди і
робить її абсолютно неможливою для
отримання нашими військовими Звісно це в
першу чергу є порушення норм Конституції
України і в другу чергу це абсолютно
очевидно несправедливий підхід тому що
якщо не вистачає в бюджеті коштів то
Влада має про це говорити
Влада має запропонувати секвестр бюджету
Усі ми відчули що не вистачає на
додаткову винагороду яку точно ми маємо
забезпечити для наших військових і
замість того щоб зробити якісь
виключення Влада запропонувала відмінити
всім виплату цієї винагороди що є
абсолютно точно несправедливим що є
абсолютно точно неприйнятним ми чітко
даємо собі відповідь і розуміючи що ми
якраз
антипопулісти Ми хочемо запропонувати те
що є на поверхні чим ми можемо
скористатися для того щоб забезпечити
виплати нашим військовим продовжити їх
виплачувати це не нові виплати це
продовження повернення виплат військовим
які мають їх отримувати Отже ми
подивилися ще раз уважно на бюджет і про
понуємо розглянути зараз при розгляді
одного з проектів законів до другого
читання такі додаткові ресурси
перше стосується
надходжень скорочення видатків на
дорожній фонд Ми всі прекрасно знаємо що
у нас
є грантові кошти Європейського Союзу які
виділяються зараз на відбудову на
ремонти необхідних інфраструктурних
об'єктів тому безболісно ми можемо взяти
75% з коштів запланованих на будівництво
доріг і спрямувати в потрібному напрямку
друга стаття у цього розпорядника це
якраз погашення боргових зобов'язань в
нас є уже заява шмигеля в нас є
підтвердження того що всі ці 18
мільярдів не будуть сплачуватися по
борговим зобов'язанням оскільки вони
відтерміновані до 2024 року Отже це
кошти вільні Таким чином з дорожнього
фонду ми можемо взяти 51 млрд 136 млн
наступне
стосується
Ну вже всім мені здається зрозумілих І
незрозумілих з точки зору економічної
витрат на фінансування телеканалів про
що ми вам ще докладніше розкажемо але
саме один мільярд 661 66 млн - Це ті
кошти щоби привести просто
кількість витрачання коштів до рівня
22-го року це це саме на цю суму
збільшено витрати В 23-му році в той час
коли військовим Немає коштів наступне це
приведення видатків по деяким
підрозділам по деяким розпорядникам до
рівня підняття в видатків на оплату
праці по всім буквально нашим бюджетним
розпорядникам але чомусь прокуратурі
збільшили
більше чим всім на 731 млн і далі
наступний слайд будь ласка і далі крім
прокуратури і ще таке ж саме
непропорційне збільшення зробили
державну бюро розслідувань на 379
мільйонів Давайте жити всі за однаковими
правилами це буде правильно і це буде
зрозуміло для всіх
наступне
абсолютно очевидним що тих коштів
53 млрд 912 мільйонів
вистачить частково на повернення виплат
але тепер Давайте розглянемо дохідну
частину А що в нас відбувається з
доходами в країні чи ми можемо зараз
оптимізувати те що раніше або йшло
кудись в окремі кармани або взагалі було
в якісь нелегальній площині і ось
почнемо із саме тих видів діяльності в
Україні які існували під час війни
не можу стверджуватися де вони
керувалися де в них був центральний офіс
але це точно коли задіюються велика
кількість банків роблять різні
нелегальні операції із платіжними
системами це вже виглядає на
кримінальній правопорушення
180 млрд це нелегальний оборот через
схеми з банками які провели в сфері
грального бізнесу як легальні так і
нелегальні організатори грального
бізнесу якщо взяти порахувати Якщо ці
кошти зараз влада нам свято обіцяє що
легальний бізнес під їх контролем тому
що саме ми піднімали вже питання
декілька разів Тоді необхідно його
зупинити знову заборонити в Україні і не
говорити нічого про те що він у нас
легальній площині якщо він в легальній
площині і ви берете на себе
відповідальність шановні представники
влади тоді будь ласка ви маєте отримати
бюджет 2023 року 23 млрд 166 мільйонів
це податок на доходи військових збір з
виграшів гравців обов'язково який має
утримуватися як утримуються з любих
доходів починаючи від малозабезпечених
до пенз- закінчуючи пенсіонерами які
отримують там відсотки навіть по
депозитам і податок з доходу
організаторів азартних Ігор який також
залежить всього-на-всього від контролю
який має організувати влада це все
реально Тим більше що
вони взяли на себе це зобов'язання
наступне ми хочемо загострити увагу на
зерновому коридорі
яка вже не один раз розглядалась на
засіданні тимчасової слідчої комісії про
те що
за декілька місяців
через зерновий коридор було фіктивно
загружено
зернових на 79 млрд грн це ви пам'ятаєте
до 300 компаній які не вирощували
зернові в Україні які закупляли їх за
безцінь за готівку
фермерів і в інших
господарів які мали невеликі обсяги
вирощеної продукції і Якщо зараз
застосувати норми прийнятого закону про
експортне забезпечення тобто навіть якщо
такі компанії попадають по якимось
окремим спискам які знову десь
регулюються в якихось офісах і
встановлюється там черговість а не
прозора черговість для кожного виробника
аграрія то ми отримаємо 11 млрд 98
мільйонів податків на додану вартість -
це як засіб який запропоновано прийнятим
законом для для режиму експортного
забезпечення це 14% від цього обороту
далі ми говоримо про ще одну велику
проблему в Україні Ми добре знаємо що в
нас тютюновий ринок в тіні Ми добре
знаємо і чули обіцянки цієї влади що на
етапі їх передвиборчих
обіцянок вони говорили що з тінню будуть
боротися по справжньому насправді є
зараз інформація і говорять вони про це
відкрито що от першим таким для них
першої перемогою стало закриття
тютюнової фабрики в Жовтих Водах
спеціалісти в цій галузі знають про що
мова йде тому якщо врахувати що
ця тютюнова фабрика займала 3% тіньового
ринку як це озвучують в тому числі і на
таких же слідчих групах то ми
спрямовуючи всі надходження до
державного бюджету отримаємо додатково
два з половиною трошки більше двох з
половиною мільярдів гривень
Таким чином ми сконцентруємо в бюджеті
90 мільярдів
715 мільйонів це буде загальна сума
доходів якщо можна поверніться будь
ласка на нашу загальну суму доходів які
ми можемо доходів і скорочення видатків
якими можемо спрямувати
на забезпечення і тут ми пропонуємо
зараз внести в бюджетну статтю яка буде
говорити що установити оці всі види
додаткових
доходів і перерозподілу витрат ми маємо
спрямувати виключно на відновлення
виплат військовослужбовцям збройних сил
України щомісячної додатковий винагороди
в розмірі 30 тисяч гривень незалежно від
покладених на таких осіб завдань чи
районів проходження служби Мені здається
що абсолютно очевидно підтримуючи 48
поправку в залі про яку з якою ми почали
ми даємо
можливість розглянути наші пропозиції
для того щоб зробити перший крок по
відновленню виплати 30 тисяч